-It's great to have you back
in New York.
This is your first Marvel movi
since "Endgame."
-Yes, yes.
-Does it feel like --
I mean, it must feel like
the beginning of something new
or do you have the relief
of not having to keep secret
about "Endgame" anymore?
-It's so nice,
especially with this one,
because it picks up
right after "Endgame," so th
press before it came out was
you couldn't really reveal
you know,
who was still with us
and who was not.
-Yeah.
-So it's really great.
I mean, it's so fun.
This movie is funny.
And it's sort of -- We're trying
to like lighten the mood.
-Yeah, you need to,
like post-"Endgame," just like
have a little like,
"Hey, everybody, we're --"
-Everybody, there is a bunch
of teenagers hanging out.
-We're going to Europe!
-Yeah.
Come on. Summer vacay.
Yeah. But I'm the adult.
I'm the adult.
-Yeah.
-Me and Sam.
As you can see from the clip
we're sort of the parental
guidance.
-Yeah.
-We try to get him back --
back to work and help us out
-Your husband, Taran,
a dear friend of mine,
he is a huge comic book fan.
-Yes.
-And over the years,
when you've received
these scripts
under top-secret circumstances
does he get a peek, or do yo
keep it from him, as well?
-Well, like, he's only allowed
to have sex with one woman..
-Oh, okay.
-...which is me.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a good rule.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Hard fact.
-I didn't expect that response
-Yeah. Yeah.
-So thank you very much.
So I feel like it's only fair.
Like, I feel like that is,
you know --
that's how I can repay him
for never --
-I see.
-For never --
-Oh, that's so nice of you
-Isn't it?
So I don't know what I get
-Yeah.
-I don't know what, like,
I get in return,
but, no, he gets to
read everything.
I feel like Marvel's
cool with that.
-Yeah. I think so, too.
-We're married.
-Is my wife going to be cool
when I come home tonight and go,
"You owe me spoilers!"
[ Laughter ]
-Give me all your scripts!
Who's going to survive this?
Yeah. No.
And he loves it.
It's his -- it's his love.
-Yes, he does love it.
-He is like a huge fan.
-He also Instagramed some
pictures.
You guys went to the Big Slick
which is a great charity event
in Kansas City with a lot
of our friends.
-Yes, yes.
-And there's a charity
softball game.
-Yes.
-And are you competitive?
-I'm super competitive.
And okay.
-There you are on the field.
-I'm very excited about
this picture, because look
this is the cross-leg catch.
-Yeah.
-I don't know what, like,
I'm about to fall over,
but I got it.
-Yeah. That I will say, like
from right here, this looks,
like, so kick ass.
It's like real weird.
-It's like, "Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
"Okay!"
-Yeah, like, I don't remembe
a single little league coach
being, like,
"When the ball comes,
you want to cross those legs."
-Cross those legs.
[ Laughter ]
-And then just kind of tip
-Lose your balance.
-Kind of tip a little.
-Lose your balance. Yeah. No
But that -- I wish that was,
like, an out but it hit
the ground,
and then, I caught it.
But I did --
-That counts for something
-For me, I mean,
it's a lot of pressure.
You're on the field.
-Yeah.
-And it's like there's
a professional team
watching you.
And as there is a whole,
you know, a whole stadium
full of people watching you.
And you just want to make
contact...
-Yes.
-...with that ball when yo
go up to the plate.
-Yes.
-And I did. I hit it right away.
And I got a double.
-There you go, that's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I felt very good about myself
-The last time I did anythin
like that, the first time up
I popped up in the infield
-Okay.
-But I was like, "All right, you
know what, get my timing back.
-It's out there.
-And then, the next time
I went up, the celebrity coach
who was an ex-baseball player,
pulled me aside, he was like
"how do you feel
about bunting?"
And I was like, "Jesus!
I'm not going to bunt...
-That's more tricky.
-...in a charity softball game!"
-Yes. Yes. Yes.
-No!
-No. So what did you do?
-I took my money back --
I donated money to charity
I took it back.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's your fault,
celebrity coach.
That's your fault.
-You have a television sho
coming out that is also
based on a comic.
-Yes!
-"Stumptown" by one
of my favorite -- based on a
comic by one of my favorite --
Greg Rucka is a great --.
-He is the greatest.
-Yeah.
-I'm so happy you know him
Because he's, like,
such a talented person.
-And this is a great book.
-Yeah.
-This is sort of out of --
this is a comic,
but it's very much out
of the superhero world.
-It is. She's like a --
she was in the military,
but she is dealing with
a lot of obstacles.
She has PTSD.
She has addictions.
Through the series,
we're going to see her sort of
become a private investigato
and mess things up, kind of,
along the way.
-That's really cool.
And I can't wait for that.
-Yeah.
-I also want to talk about you
kids, 10 and 4.
And I'm assuming --
which age is this?
I don't -- I guess this
must be the 10-year-old.
-Okay. That's the 10-year-old,
but it was a while --
Like, it was maybe 2 years ago
-Okay. Okay, gotcha.
-So I came down to the kitchen
and I just -- I found this
on the kitchen table.
-And this is --
I mean, this is a criminal act
This is a forgery.
-Yes.
-They wrote a note...
-Full-on forgery.
-...as if you had written it
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I gave birth to this child
-Okay.
-Okay?
-Then they wrote a note as you
-And this is how he repays me.
-And do you want to read i
real quick?
-"I am a monkey with a big butt,
and I farts with my butt."
[ Laughter ]
-It is so vague.
-"Cobie. Cobie."
-Yeah. The fact that she said --
I love the idea that she think
adults write things like this,
and then leave them out.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Just a reminder.
I just, like, leaving reminders.
But, yeah, that's what you get
-That's what you get.
-That's what you get for years
of raising your child
and providing her
with love and support.
-I read this and I now don't -
I think I might not teach
my kids how to handwrite.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
That's a smart --
that's a smart instinct.
-Seems like only bad thing
can happen.
Thanks so much for being here.
It's always so great to see you.
That's Cobie Smulders,
everybody.